hey 42 here Siberia is vast so vast that
if it declared independence from Russia
it would instantly become the largest
country on Earth
about a third of this vast Wilderness is
dominated by the tiger a colossal Forest
about one and a half times the size of
India and it was deep in the heart of
this Endless Sea of trees that one of
the most mysterious natural disasters in
modern history took place just over 100
years ago on the 30th of June 1908 a
huge section of the East Siberian tiger
was leveled by
something
the sheer scale of Devastation was
breathtaking 80 million trees across
almost a thousand square miles were
felled in what can only be described as
a pocket-sized apocalypse it looked as
though someone had dropped a nuclear
bomb in the middle of the Siberian
Wilderness it except nuclear weapons
wouldn't be invented for another 40
years and no human explosive in
existence at the time could have caused
anywhere near that level of Destruction
so if it wasn't a wmd that leveled a
thousand square miles of Siberian Forest
over a century ago
what on Earth was it
[Music]
in 1927 Russian mineralogist Leonard
colick ventured to the remote site near
the parkamnia tunguska river armed with
a team of scientists A handful of local
guides and a theory Kulik believed only
one thing could possibly explain this
remarkable Russian ruination
a meteor strike
to begin with his investigation
supported that hypothesis the Fallen
trees all pointed in the same direction
and by following them the team reached
what was clearly some kind of Ground
Zero but it was there that Kulik found
something that simply didn't make sense
or to be precise what he didn't find
made no sense
there was no impact crater nor was there
a meteorite not even fragments even
stranger where the crater should have
been the trees were still standing
upright but were bereft of bark and
branches
it was Bloody bizarre unserious
questions remain even today this is the
story of the Tomb gusker event a mystery
that has stumped science for more than
100 years
whatever it was that flattened a
thousand square miles of forest in
Siberia in 1908 its effects reverberated
around the world for several days
afterwards seismic stations across
Europe and Asia registered an activity
Spike resembling a mid-sized earthquake
and an air-based Shockwave was detected
5 000 miles away in Papua New Guinea and
Washington DC
he didn't even need sensitive scientific
equipment to see that something strange
was going on night skies across half the
world were illuminated by an eerie light
for days this odd luminescence was so
bright people could take photos and read
newspapers outside in the middle of the
night
eyewitness accounts from near Ground
Zero are sparse because well Siberia is
sparse it's one of the least densely
populated places on Earth
hence a thousand square miles of forest
were obliterated yet the estimated death
toll stands at a whopping
free not three thousand not three
hundred just three
those who were unlucky enough to be
nearby at the time all tell a similar
Tale
in the early hours of the morning of the
30th of June 1908 a strange blue white
light appeared high up in the sky so
bright it looked like a second sun
this light slowly moved towards the
horizon over the course of 10 minutes or
so at which point the sky suddenly
filled with flames
shortly afterwards came a series of loud
bangs that sounded like artillery fire
and assumingly hot Shockwave demolished
buildings blew out windows and threw
people off their feet knocking many
unconscious
plausible explanation for such want and
Destruction has eluded scientists for
decades the site is incredibly remote
which has seriously hampered
investigations and what we have found
barely even makes sense
the lack of an impact crater meant a
meteor strike was out
there aren't volcanoes in the area and
whilst earthquakes can knock down trees
they don't generate Airborne shock waves
or bright lights in the sky with the
obvious explanations not fitting the
evidence people sought more extreme
Alternatives the general belief amongst
the locals at the time was that the
Carnage was caused by an Angry God
called ogdi others blames the appearance
of a rogue primordial black hole or the
annihilation of a particle of antimatter
especially excitable types of a ponchon
for wearing tin foil have linked the
event to an accident involving Nikola
Tesla's famed death rate or even the
detonation of a nuclear-powered alien
spacecraft
for obvious reasons none of these
theories have ever gained traction
within serious scientific circles but if
we've ruled out all of the obvious
explanations and plenty of really
stupid ones
what's left
if you think you figured it out now
would be the time to pause the video and
smugly put your idea in the comments for
everyone else I think it's time for a
clue one that comes from the most
unexpected of places an obscure
Australian explosives test codenamed
operation blowdown this unusual
experiment was carried out in a remote
corner of Northern Queensland in 1963.
its purpose was to see what happens when
you detonate a really big bomb in the
middle of the Jungle rumor Hazard the
whole thing was a covert feasibility
test for dropping nukes on Vietnam
though for obvious reasons that's never
been confirmed in the experiment 45 tons
of TNT was designated 20 meters above
the rainforest canopy the subsequent
explosion flattens the forest for
several hundred meters in every
direction except for one directly
beneath the bomb the tree still stood
their limbs unbarked seared away
it was tungoska in miniature
but wait a second haven't we already
established that no bomb in existence in
1908 could possibly have caused a tune
goscar event well yes yes we have but it
wasn't a bomb not exploded over Siberia
a hundred years ago it was a meteor as
you probably already know most
meteorites headed our way burn up in the
atmosphere long before they reached the
surface that's what shooting stars are
only an estimated five to ten percent
actually make it to the ground but it
turns out meteorites don't have to smash
into Terra Firma to wreak havoc because
under the right circumstances the
immense heat generated during a
meteorite's fall to Earth will cause it
to blow itself to Pieces releasing vast
amounts of energy in an instant
anything or anyone lucky enough to be
directly underneath at the time is going
to have a very very bad day
these misanthropic meteorites are known
as Air Bursts and it's widely believed
that one was behind the tungusker event
according to computer models the
meteorite which was about 60 meters
across and traveling at a face melting
60 000 miles an hour detonated five
miles above Earth's surface with an
explosive force equal to 2 000 little
boys that's the name of the nuclear bomb
dropped on Hiroshima I haven't been
blowing up children if those numbers are
correct tunguska comfortably holds the
record as the biggest meteorite event in
recorded history and a large meteor air
burst certainly seems to fit the
available evidence it would explain the
appearance of the second sun-like light
in the sky and the burst part accounts
for the Shockwave even the Eerie lights
that lit up the night sky make sense
they would have been caused by sunlight
reflecting off dust particles shed by
the meteor As It sped through the upper
atmosphere
and in the 90s Italian researchers found
large quantities of nickel Cobalt and
chromium in resin extracted from nearby
trees which are rather out of place
elements in those parts they are however
found in high levels in most meteorites
for these reasons and others the air
burst theory is by far the most popular
explanation today but not everybody is
entirely convinced in 2002 a German cut
astrophysicist Wolfgang that is
proposed a radically different
possibility that the disaster was caused
by the biggest deadliest fart in history
a thought not of human origin but
strayed from the bowels of the Earth
itself
according to Mr the destruction of
tunguska was the result of the ignition
of 10 million tons of natural gas
released from within the Earth's crust
as slightly mad as that may sound
similar events have been witnessed
elsewhere usually connected with
Subterranean volcanic activity and it
would explain why relatively little
meteoric material has been found at the
tunguska site
in 2020 a Russian research team came up
with yet another hypothesis based on the
results of hundreds of computer
simulations they concluded that tunguska
was the result of a so-called Earth
Grazer a kind of meteorite that enters
Earth's atmosphere as a shallower enough
angle that it leaves again without
impacting the surface
Earth Graces can still generate
destructive shock waves if they get
close enough to the ground and like the
giant fart Theory this one explains the
relative lack of extraterrestrial
material recovered from the site
whatever the cause it's worth
remembering just how close Humanity came
to what could have been the worst
natural disaster in human history the
tomboska blast was big enough to utterly
destroy any city on earth killing
hundreds of thousands of people in the
process and next time we might not be so
lucky
oh and there will be a next time it's
just a matter of when and where there
are tens of millions of asteroids
bouncing around our solar system and we
only have good data on a tiny fraction
of them our ability to detect and
monitor them has increased exponentially
over the last few decades but as of
today we've only ever tracked seven
asteroids before they impacted Earth
considering around 20 of fortitude hits
the surface every single day that's a
bit of a worrying stat we're the
planetary equivalent of a drunk boxer
carrying on the ropes as unseen punches
rain down on us from all sides all we
can do is pray that the knockout blow
Never Lands
we have near misses all the time too in
early 2023 a city-killing asteroid about
90 meters across whisked by the Earth
well inside the moon's orbit we didn't
even know it existed until about a month
before had it been on cause for London
New York Tokyo Well we'd all have been
okay before you go out and invest
your life savings in a bunker it's time
for the good news it's true that we only
have solid data on a tiny fraction of
all asteroids in the solar system but
that tiny fraction includes almost all
the really big ones there's pretty much
zero chance of an Extinction event
asteroid sneaking up and doing us like
the last one did the dinosaurs
the city killers though are a bit more
worrying according to the European Space
Agency we've spotted significantly less
than one percent of those but asteroids
of that size only impact the Earth on
average about once every thousand years
or so and even if one does happen to be
heading our way chances are good that it
won't be such a big deal over 50 of the
global population lives in cities but
those cities only cover about two
percent of the total land area of the
planet and that isn't even accounting
for the two-thirds of Earth that's
covered in water a direct hit from a
large asteroid one shotting the big city
while it's not impossible would be
monumentally unlucky
in 2016 the United Nations announced
that asteroid day would be celebrated
around the world to raise awareness of
the possibility that we might all get
brutally murdered by rocks from space at
any given moment
fittingly asteroid day is celebrated
every year on the 30th of June a nod to
the tungusker event and a small reminder
of what happened the last time the
universe got bored and Unleashed it
ruinous fury on planet Earth
thanks for watching